It's an interesting question
about finding people early on,
especially those first
couple of key hires,
which can give you a lot of anxiety
because you feel like you're betting
the whole company on those first,
especially the first one.
But the first two or three, and people
will tell you that the first ten can
make or break your company,
and it's absolutely true.
For me, what I usually did was find
fans of the product in the community.
Because typically, I wasn't looking for,
in the early days, technical skills
because I was able to do that work.
And super enthusiastic users that
loved the product were the best
people to bring in.
So I remember the first person,
I told you, I had trouble with
operations, it turned out somebody that
loved the product had been
an accountant in a previous life.
And so I brought him in, and
he sort of took over all that for me.
Oddly enough,
my second employer was my wife.
And she was amazing,
a little difficult to work with, but
[LAUGH] did a great job.
And but yeah, for me, it was actually
finding users of the product that had
skills, so they were already passionate.
They were all excited, and
I've seen this model elsewhere.
37 Signals talks about this too,
they find people that already
use the product,
they're really passionate about it.
They're active in the community,
helping people already in forums.
But this is the best people because
they've already sort of self-selected,
based on their passion for the product.
In my experience, finding people that
are already passionate about your
product, even just a tiny,
you're going to have a tiny audience
at that point when it's just you.
But that's great,
that those people are super passionate.
They sought you out.
And so finding people with the skills
you need in that group has always really
worked well for me throughout my
sort of entrepreneurial career.